From WBEZ Chicago, it's This American Life, distributed by Public Radio International. I'm Ira Glass.
来自芝加哥WBEZ电台，《美国生活》节目，由国际公共电台发行。我是艾拉·格拉斯。
[RINGTONE]
[手机铃声]
Hello?
喂？
Hey, dad?
嘿，爸？
Hi. Let me pick this up on another phone. I can barely hear you.
嗨。让我换个电话接听，我几乎听不清你的声音。
About a year ago, this thing happened to me when I took the train down to visit my dad in Baltimore. And when this thing happened, he said to me, you know, this could be a story on your show.
大约一年前，我坐火车去巴尔的摩看望我父亲时，发生了一件事。当这件事发生时，他对我说：“你知道吗，这可以成为你节目里的一个故事。”
So this week, I called him up to have him and my stepmom tell the story.
所以这周，我给他打了电话，让他们（我父亲和继母）把这个故事讲出来。
You remember what happened with the business with the train and your suit? You left it on the train. It was in a hanging bag, and you left it on the compartment over your seat by mistake. So I said, "Well, what are you going to do?" And you said, "Well--"
你还记得火车和西装的那件事吗？你把它落在火车上了。它在挂衣袋里，你不小心把它落在了座位上方的行李架上。所以我问：“那你打算怎么办？”你说：“嗯……”
I said, well, apparently you can go to Amtrak and they'll retrieve your luggage at the train's next stop and throw it onto the next Amtrak that's headed back to you.
我说，显然你可以去美国铁路公司（Amtrak），他们会把你的行李在火车的下一站取回，然后扔上下一班开往你那里的火车。
But the problem was my dad had tickets to the Baltimore Symphony that night, and train that was hopefully going to arrive with my suit, that is, if everything went perfectly, perfectly, perfectly, that train would arrive--
但问题是，我父亲那天晚上有巴尔的摩交响乐团的票，如果一切完美无缺，那列本应载着我西装的火车，应该会到达——
I think 6:30, as I remember, or quarter of 7, and the symphony was at 8 o'clock.
我记得是6点半，或者6点45分左右，而音乐会是8点开始。
So of course, this was very, very worrisome.
所以这当然非常、非常令人担忧。
And before I go any further in this story, I should say, this is the 400th episode one of our radio show. There are eight of us who make the show, working together really closely, finding stories and shaping them. And for years, as we made those 399 other episodes, all those years, family members have approached us at weddings, holidays, with all kinds of ideas for the show. Most of them never made it onto the air, because-- i'll be frank-- they were not so great.
在继续讲故事之前，我应该说明一下，这是我们广播节目的第400期。我们有八个人共同制作这档节目，工作非常紧密，寻找故事并塑造它们。多年来，在我们制作那399期节目时，家人们总是在婚礼、节日里向我们提出各种节目点子。大部分都没能播出，因为——坦白说——它们不太精彩。
And this week we thought, OK. It's our 400th show. We should do something we've never done before. Something so difficult we've never dared do it before. And we thought, you know, after tackling all the subjects we have over the years-- productions of Peter Pan gone awry, and investigations into Guantanamo, and trying to make the history of mortgage-backed securities into entertaining radio-- what would be the greatest challenge? What would be the greatest challenge that we could possibly attempt for our 400th show?
这周我们想，好吧，这是我们的第400期节目。我们应该做一些以前从未做过的事情。一些难到我们从未敢尝试过的事情。我们想，在处理了多年来这么多主题之后——《彼得·潘》演砸了，对关塔那摩的调查，试图将抵押贷款支持证券的历史变成有趣的广播——什么才是最大的挑战？我们400期节目能尝试的最大挑战是什么？
And the answer? Obviously, let's do all of those stories pitched to us by our parents. Stories where it's not even clear whether it's humanly possible to make them into listenable stories on the radio.
答案呢？显然，我们就做那些父母们向我们推荐的故事吧。那些甚至不确定是否能将其制作成可听的广播节目的故事。
So hence this story with the suit. OK, you remember where we are? OK. We're worried about the train and the suit.
所以就有了这个西装的故事。好吧，你记得我们讲到哪儿了吗？我们在担心火车和那套西装。
And we were mulling around about what to do about it, and meanwhile eating some late lunch.
我们在琢磨该怎么办，同时还在吃顿晚午餐。
And it was at lunch that my stepmom, Sandy, got an idea. Let's buy a cheap suit at Marshalls just in case the train doesn't come in.
就在午餐时，我继母桑迪想到了一个主意。为了以防火车没到，我们去Marshalls商场买套便宜的西装吧。
Marshalls is nearby. I've seen a lot of suits there that were a really good price. Sometimes a hundred dollars. And you know, it could work.
Marshalls就在附近。我在那儿见过很多价格非常优惠的西装。有时只要一百美元。你知道，这可能行得通。
And your plan was, we're going to buy a suit. Let's try to get a suit for like a hundred bucks with the thought that if I don't wear it, you'll just return it the next day.
你的计划是，我们去买套西装。我们试着买一套一百美元左右的，如果我不用穿，第二天就退掉。
That's right.
没错。
We didn't have much time, so we hustled over to Marshalls, where we learned that Marshalls actually doesn't sell many suits. They literally have two suits in the store. Miraculously, one fits.
我们没太多时间，于是匆匆赶往Marshalls，结果发现那里其实没卖多少西装。店里总共就两套。奇迹般地，有一套合身。
But another obstacle. The pants. The pants need hemming. Though if we hem them, of course, we wouldn't be able to return to suit. What to do? What do we do?
但还有另一个障碍。裤子。裤子需要缝边。如果我们缝了边，当然就不能退了。怎么办？我们该怎么办？
And I said, uh, scotch tape. Scotch tape it.
我说，呃，用透明胶带。用透明胶带粘一下。
So that was the plan.
计划就是这样。
It went off like a great bank heist. Like The Sting. Like Ocean's 11. I got the suit at Marshalls. The train came in. It had my real suit. I change into the real suit at the back of the train station. We go to the Baltimore Symphony, which was, by the way, fantastic. They got this new conductor. We went home, removed the scotch tape from the suit, and returned it on Monday.
过程就像一场伟大的银行抢劫。就像电影《骗中骗》或《十一罗汉》。我在Marshalls买了西装。火车到了。上面有我真正的西装。我在火车站后面换上了真西装。我们去了巴尔的摩交响乐团，顺便说一下，演出太棒了。他们换了位新指挥。我们回家后，把西装上的透明胶带拆掉，周一就把它退了。
Everything came out great. And it was just like a normal visit from you, Ira.
一切都很顺利。就像你平时的造访一样，艾拉。
What do you mean by that?
你这话是什么意思？
Well, you know, sometimes things like this happen.
嗯，你知道，有时就会发生这样的事。
Wait, what do you mean? What kinds of things?
等等，什么意思？是什么样的事？
You know, it's always excitement when you come to Baltimore.
你知道，你来巴尔的摩总是很热闹。
Are you saying that this thing that happens every time I come is that there's some kind of unnecessary chaos?
你是说我每次来发生的事情都是那种没必要的混乱吗？
I wouldn't say that. I wouldn't say that.
我不会那样说的。我不会那样说。
No?
不？
No.
不。
Now, you know, usually, a story on the show, for it to work, it needs to kind of have some bigger idea, or some bigger universal thing that it drives towards. Do you think there is something like that with this story?
你知道，通常节目里的一个故事要成功，它需要有一个更大的主题，或者某种通用的东西。你觉得这个故事有吗？
No, not at all.
不，完全没有。
Well, at least he could tell.
好吧，至少他能看出来。
Today, for our 400th show, each of us who work on the radio show went to our parents, got them to pitch the story-- or repitched one that they had pitched in the past-- and then the idea was, we each had to make the story they pitched.
今天，为了我们的400期节目，我们每个制作人都去找了自己的父母，让他们推荐故事——或者是重提他们过去推荐过的点子——然后我们的计划是，每个人都必须制作他们推荐的故事。
But there is more. Musical transition, please?
但还有更多。请来一段音乐过渡？
So we're gathered here, not in our studio, which actually isn't big enough for all of us to fit, but in our office, in the room where we have our weekly story meetings. So it's nine of us sitting here with microphones and looking around the room. It's Robyn Semien--
我们现在聚在一起，不在我们的录音室，因为那儿坐不下我们所有人，而是在我们的办公室，我们每周开故事会议的房间里。所以我们九个人坐在这里，拿着麦克风，环顾四周。这是罗宾·塞米恩——
Hi.
嗨。
Jane Feltes--
简·费尔特斯——
Hi.
嗨。
Alissa Shipp--
阿丽莎·希普——
Present.
到。
Seth Lind--
塞斯·林德——
Yeah.
嘿。
That's our production manager, Seth Lind. Sarah Koenig--
那是我们的制作经理塞斯·林德。莎拉·凯尼格——
Hello.
你好。
Alex Blumberg--
亚历克斯·布隆伯格——
Hello.
你好。
That would be Lisa Pollak, jumping the gun. And finally, our senior producer, Julie Snyder.
那是莉莎·波拉克，抢话了。最后，我们的资深制作人朱莉·斯奈德。
Hello.
你好。
Nervous. One of our producers, Nancy Updike, was called away and isn't here.
我很紧张。我们的制作人之一南希·厄普代克被叫走了，不在这里。
But we're gathered here together today because not only are all of you attempting to execute some of the most difficult stories you ever have-- if that were not hard enough, we're going to make it a contest.
但我们今天聚在一起，是因为你们不仅要尝试制作你们有史以来最难的故事——如果这还不够难的话，我们还要把它变成一场竞赛。
The ground rules are these. We're going to play each producer's story. We'll all listen together. And then at the end of the show, we're going to come back on the air together and decide which story was best. Not only will this determined once and for all who is the greatest producer in radio, there's a prize that we all decided on together at our real story meaning.
基本规则如下：我们会播放每位制作人的故事。大家一起听。在节目最后，我们会一起回到直播间，决定哪个故事最好。这不仅能一劳永逸地选出广播界最伟大的制作人，还有一个我们一起定下的奖品。
I forgot what the prize is.
我忘了奖品是什么了。
Is it that the winning parent gets a plane ticket to come visit their child producer?
是不是获胜的父母可以得到一张机票来探望他们的制作人孩子？
And that's how I refer to all of you, as child producers.
我就是这样称呼你们所有人的，孩子制作人。
But we also acknowledge that maybe we have no perspective on these stories, because who has perspective on their own family and their ideas? And so we also want to turn to you, everybody listening over the radio. You will all hear these stories. At the end of the program, go to our website and vote for your favorite. And if you listeners vote for a different winter than we choose amongst ourselves, then a second parent will get a trip to see their kid.
但我们也承认，也许我们对这些故事毫无客观性，因为谁又能客观对待自己家庭的点子呢？所以我们想转而求助你们，每一位听广播的人。你们会听到这些故事。在节目结束时，去我们的网站为你最喜欢的投票。如果我们听众选出的获胜者和我们内部选出的不同，那么第二位父母也将获得探亲之旅。
Wow.
哇。
Oh, nice!
哦，太棒了！
All right. And so let the games begin. Our first story is from Lisa Pollak.
好吧。游戏开始。第一个故事来自莉莎·波拉克。
It's funny what your parents forget to tell you until you're recording them for national broadcast. Here's what my mom said when I asked her for a story idea.
直到你为全国广播录制时，你才会发现父母们忘了告诉你什么。当我向我妈要故事点子时，她是这么说的。
What if you get the story on planning your funerals before you die? Because that's what we're doing now.
如果你能在死前做个关于策划葬礼的故事怎么样？因为我们现在就在做这个。
She explained that she and my dad had recently bought their cemetery plots. Apparently all their friends were making plans for eternity, and they got they should jump on the bandwagon, too. I wasn't really sure why she was laughing, but she seemed convinced there was a funny idea in here, somewhere.
她解释说她和我爸最近买了墓地。显然所有的朋友都在为永恒做计划，他们觉得也该随大流了。我不太明白她为什么笑，但她似乎坚信这其中有个有趣的点子。
There's got to be funny stories about death, and they've never done that on your show.
关于死亡肯定有有趣的故事，你们节目从没做过那个。
Yeah, we have. We have. What do you mean, a funny story about death?
不，我们做过。我们做过的。你指的关于死亡的有趣故事是什么意思？
Yeah. Not death, but dying and, you know, the burial things.
是的。不是死亡本身，而是濒死，你知道，那种埋葬的事情。
Well, have you been to any funny funerals?
好吧，你去过什么有趣的葬礼吗？
I went to one hysterical funeral. I started laughing. And dad was laughing. You know when you start to laugh and then you're trying to stifle it because you're at a funeral? I was busting a gut. I was laughing so hard. And dad too. What was so funny? What was so funny Mitch? It with the whole-- I don't know what. It was just fabulous! It was the best funeral I've ever been to.
我去过一场歇斯底里的葬礼。我开始笑。我爸也在笑。你知道当你开始大笑却试图克制，因为你在葬礼上吗？我当时笑得肚子疼。笑得太厉害了。我爸也是。什么那么好笑？米奇，什么那么好笑？总之——我不知道。太精彩了！那是我参加过最好的葬礼。
So this is the idea. Find funny stories about funerals. Stories kind of like my mom's, only actually explaining the funny parts.
所以这就是点子。寻找关于葬礼的有趣故事。像我妈那种，但要解释清楚好笑的地方。
I started looking, and the first thing I found was a New York Times story from January 1902. Clearly I wasn't the first reporter whose mother had this idea. The headline read, "Humors of Funerals: The Funny Side of a Gruesome Subject As Seen by Clergymen." Or, as I like to imagine a clergyman would say it in 1902--
我开始寻找，第一件事就是1902年1月的《纽约时报》故事。显然我不是第一个母亲有这个点子的记者。标题写着：“葬礼的幽默：牧师眼中的可怕主题之有趣一面。”或者，就像我想象中1902年的牧师会说的那样——
"The Funny Side of a Gruesome Subject, As Seen By Clergymen."
“牧师眼中的可怕主题之有趣一面。”
The story was a collection of anonymous anecdotes, gets like this one.
那个故事是一系列匿名轶事，比如这个。
The first Sunday after I had been installed in my first church, I discovered there was to be a funeral, and was asked to officiate. On asking who was dead, I learned it was a child of seven days whose mother had died in the county poorhouse, and the accident of whose advent into the world was in defiance of at least one item of the decalogue. I thought, of course there would be no mourners.
在我进入第一个教堂后的第一个星期天，我发现有个葬礼，受邀主持。问起死者是谁，我得知是一个七天大的孩子，母亲死于县穷人院，这个孩子的出生违背了十诫中的至少一条。我想，当然不会有悼念者了。
OK. So the setup's a little dark. But then, to the clergyman's surprise, a whole crowd of mourners show up. They bring food--
好吧。开头有点阴暗。但令牧师惊讶的是，一大群悼念者出现了。他们带着食物——
And a real picnic scene outspread itself around the church. It was the sexton who, on seeing my surprise, explained in all seriousness, "You see, parson, there has been neither a lynching nor a wedding in this section for so long, that the people have to make the most they can out of a funeral."
在教堂周围展开了一场真正的野餐场景。是司事在看到我的惊讶后，严肃地解释道：“牧师，你看，我们这一带很久没有私刑也没有婚礼了，所以大家只能尽量从葬礼中找点乐子。”
OK, that didn't work.
好吧，这没用。
So I turned to a more contemporary source, a book called The Funny Side of Death, published in 2008. The author is a retired funeral home owner who says his sense of humor helped him cope with the job. On page 97, for example, he explains how dead people's hip replacements, which are metal and stay intact after cremation, can be, quote, "shined up and presented to friends as letter openers."
所以我转向了一个更现代的来源，一本2008年出版的《死亡的有趣一面》。作者是一位退休的殡仪馆老板，他说幽默感帮助他应对这份工作。例如在第97页，他解释了死者的髋关节置换物（由于是金属，火化后完好无损）如何能够被“打磨光亮，作为拆信刀送给朋友”。
At this point, I started making phone calls, first to the National Funeral Director's Association. I told them what I was looking for, and they said they had the perfect person to help me. And next thing I knew, I was on hold, waiting to talk to a funeral director in Decatur, Illinois named Randy Earl.
此时，我开始打电话，先打给全国殡葬承办人协会。我告诉他们我在找什么，他们说有完美的人选。转眼间，我就在电话那头等着，准备和伊利诺伊州迪凯特市的一位殡仪馆老板兰迪·厄尔通话。
You know, nothing puts me in the mood for a humorous anecdote like the stuff they play when on hold at the funeral home.
你知道，没什么比殡仪馆电话里的等待音乐更能让我进入幽默轶事的氛围了。
At Brintlinger and Earl Funeral Homes, we wanted to let you know about pre-arrangement planning. It's an easy way for you to take the worry of your burial or cremation needs away from your loved ones during the very difficult time--
在布林特林格和厄尔殡仪馆，我们想提醒您注意预安排规划。这是一种让您在困难时期免去亲人对您葬礼或火化需求担忧的简便方法——
Hello, this is Randy.
喂，我是兰迪。
Randy said he'd been expecting my call, and that he had a great story. It was about a man who came in one day to make prearrangements for his funeral. The man had his kids with him, and one of the things they all talked about was what music to play at the man's service.
兰迪说他一直在等我的电话，而且他有个很棒的故事。那是关于一个男人有一天进来预办葬礼。那个人带着孩子，他们讨论的一件事就是葬礼上放什么音乐。
I said, what's your favorite song? And he said, well, "Silent Night." And the kids laughed. They sort of laughed at him. And even the daughter, she said, well, Dad, what is it with "Silent Night"? And he said, well, it was at the end of the war, and they had just declared the war over. And I was sitting in a foxhole. The first song I heard was "Silent Night," and that's my favorite song. And I said, well, Bob, we'll use that at your funeral service.
我说，你最喜欢的歌是什么？他说，嗯，“平安夜”。孩子们笑了。他们有点嘲笑他。连女儿都说，爸，这“平安夜”到底怎么了？他说，嗯，那是战争结束时，他们刚宣布战争结束。我正坐在散兵坑里。我听到的第一首歌就是“平安夜”，那是我的最爱。我说，好吧，鲍勃，我们就用它做葬礼音乐。
As fate would have it, the man died in July. And at the church where the service was supposed to be, the whole "Silent Night" idea wasn't going over so well.
命中注定，那个人在七月去世了。而在原定举办仪式的教堂，整个“平安夜”的主意不太受欢迎。
The church organist calls me. And he said, that's not even in our liturgy. And he said, I'm not playing "Silent Night" when you're exiting a church. So I sat there for a minute and I said, well, I might have to get another organist. But I promised him that we're going to do this, and somehow, I am going to do this.
教堂管风琴手给我打电话。他说，这甚至不在我们的礼仪里。他说，我不打算在你要离开教堂时弹奏“平安夜”。我坐在那儿想了一会儿，我说，我可能得找别的琴手了。但我答应过他我们要这么做，无论如何，我一定要做到。
So we go to church. We have the funeral mass. And the priest told the story. Bob requested that this song be played, because it was his favorite song. And he was in a foxhole when he heard that the war was over, and this was the song he heard played right after that. And it's the middle of July. He played that very softly as we exited the church, and they started singing very quietly. And it was the most moving, powerful thing that I've experienced in a long, long time.
于是我们去了教堂。举行了安魂弥撒。牧师讲了这个故事。鲍勃要求演奏这首歌，因为是他最喜欢的。他听到战争结束时就在散兵坑里，这是他在那之后听到的第一首歌。而现在是七月中旬。我们走出教堂时，他轻轻地弹奏着，他们开始小声跟唱。那是我很长一段时间以来经历过最感人、最有力的时刻。
[MUSIC - "SILENT NIGHT"]
[音乐 - “平安夜”]
But not a funny story?
但不是有趣的故事？
No, no! It's not a funny story. It's not a funny story. It's a real story.
不，不！那不是有趣的故事。那不是幽默的。那是真实的故事。
If you're looking for funny, I'm probably not your guy. Because I'm not a funny guy with my work. Even if I did have something in my repertoire, I would not put it out on the radio. I just wouldn't do it.
如果你在找有趣的，我可能不是你要找的人。因为我在工作中不是个有趣的人。即使我的曲目里有什么，我也不会把它搬上电台。我只是不会那么做。
It turns out that in the funeral business, humor can be a touchy subject. As Ron Hast, publisher of Mortuary Management Magazine, told me--
事实证明，在殡葬业，幽默是个敏感话题。《殡葬管理杂志》的发行人罗恩·哈斯特告诉我——
There's always people who are trying to make fun. Oh, I understood that everyone's dying to come to you. Ha, ha, ha. I've heard it 5,000 times, and they think it's so funny, and they laugh, and whatever. Well, it's just stupid, is what it is.
总有人想开玩笑。哦，我知道每个人都争着来找你。哈哈哈哈。我听过五千遍了，他们觉得好笑，在那笑什么的。嗯，那叫愚蠢。
It's not funny.
那不有趣。
Ron spent so much time warning me about the pitfalls of this story idea-- how funny things don't really happen that often in his business, how outsiders like me tend to exaggerate and embellish, that when he actually gave me exactly what I was looking for, I was afraid to react. Instead of laughing, I asked a dumb question that killed his whole punchline.
罗恩花了很多时间警告我这个故事点子的陷阱——他的行业里搞笑的事情其实不常发生，像我这样的外行容易夸张和润色，所以当他真的给我讲了我想要的那个点子时，我反而不敢反应了。我不但没笑，反而问了个愚蠢的问题，把他的包袱给毁了。
There was a lady who was sitting at a funeral, and she had had her father's funeral in the same funeral home about a month before. And she happened to notice that the funeral director there, doing this funeral, that was another person, that he was wearing her father's tie. And what had happened was, she realized that when he went and shut the casket down, out of the view of the family, he liked the tie too, and took it off, and closed the lid, and kept it for himself. They went so far as to have the grave open to prove that he had taken it, and sued him.
有位女士坐在葬礼上，她一个月前刚在同一家殡仪馆办了她父亲的葬礼。她碰巧注意到殡仪馆的人正在主持另一场葬礼时，系着她父亲的领带。后来发现，当他把棺材盖上时，在家人看不见的地方，他自己也喜欢那条领带，就取下来，盖上盖子，据为己有。他们甚至闹到开棺取证，把他告了。
And he lost, I'm guessing?
我猜他输了？
I don't know what the outcome is. But you know, you don't follow all that stuff through.
我不知道结果。但你知道，你不会跟踪调查那种事。
At this point, I gave on funeral directors and called a Lutheran minister I know. His name is Duke Fries. Pastor Fries told me a story about the time he finished doing a funeral service and made this dignified exit in front of a room full of people, only to realize--
这时候，我放弃了殡仪馆老板，打给了我认识的一位路德教牧师。他叫杜克·弗里斯。弗里斯牧师给我讲了一个他在葬礼结束后，在满屋子人面前做优雅退场时，意识到——
That I had chosen the wrong door, that I was now in a closet. And I wasn't sure whether to step back out with all these people watching, or just stay in this closet until I heard them moving around, which is, in fact, what I did.
我走错了门，我进了壁橱。我不确定是该在这么多人的注视下走出来，还是就在壁橱里待着，直到听见他们在走动，事实上，我确实这么做了。
Finally, I was getting somewhere. I kept at it, and before long, I had more stories than I knew what to do with. There was the overzealous mourner who fell into the grave during the funeral, a woman who wanted to be buried topless to show off her breast job, and a funeral home worker who lifted a woman out of her bed only realize that her husband, in the next bed over, was the dead one.
终于，我有点进展了。我坚持不懈，没多久，我手里的故事比我想用的还多。有在葬礼中掉进墓坑的过度热情的悼念者，有想要裸露上身安葬以炫耀隆胸效果的女人，还有一个殡仪馆员工，他把一个女人从床上抬起来，才发现旁边床上她的丈夫才是死者。
But I wasn't so sure any of these were what my mom was looking for. None of them were like that funeral she went to, where--
但我不太确定这些是不是我妈想要的。它们不像她参加的那场葬礼——
I was busting a gut! I was laughing so hard.
我当时笑得肚子疼！笑得太厉害了。
I was just about to give up looking when our intern, Brian Reed, told me I had to call his friend Rob. So I did. And after that, I made one last call.
我正要放弃时，我们的实习生布莱恩·里德告诉我，我必须打给我朋友罗伯。所以我打了。在那之后，我打了最后一个电话。
[RINGTONE]
[手机铃声]
Hello?
喂？
Hi, mom.
嗨，妈。
Hi, Li.
嗨，莉。
So you know how I've been looking for funny funeral stories?
你知道我一直在找有趣的葬礼故事吗？
Uh huh.
嗯。
I have one I want to play for you.
我有个故事想放给你听。
OK.
好的。
Um, what's that in the background?
呃，背景里是什么声音？
I'm taking something out of the oven.
我在把东西从烤箱里拿出来。
Oh.
哦。
So there's going to be two people telling the story. Their names are Rob and Andrea. They're married, the funeral is for Andrea's grandmother. It takes place in a Ukrainian church, and they don't totally know what's going on, because the priest is speaking Ukrainian.
会有两个人讲这个故事。他们叫罗伯和安德里亚。他们结婚了，这场葬礼是安德里亚祖母的。地点在一个乌克兰教堂，他们完全不知道在干什么，因为牧师说的是乌克兰语。
OK.
好吧。
And the first thing that got us silly was that the priest looks exactly like Bill Murray. Like, exactly.
让我们发笑的第一件事是，牧师长得简直像比尔·莫瑞。真的，简直一模一样。
Like Bill Murray circa Meatballs , with the hair sticking up and the-- so they started the service, and it's all in Ukrainian. I mean, they're not speaking any English whatsoever. So the priest decides he's going to start speaking in a little bit of English, and he's reading-- apparently it's custom in the Ukrainian church, if someone passes away, you give a donation to the church in that person's name. So he literally is listing off the people's names and how much they gave to the church. And it was a good amount, he kind of smiles, he's like, "Maister Zeslinsky, $50." He gives a little smile. And if it was like a low amount, he's like, you know, "The Zogrokskis, five dollar." And he gives like a disappointing look, like oh, not good, you know? And he's doing this whole list, over and over, he goes through this whole list of money, and you know, people are adding up the money in their head.
就像《肉丸》时期的比尔·莫瑞，头发竖着……所以他们开始仪式，全是用乌克兰语。我是说，他们根本不说英语。所以牧师决定开始说一点点英语，他正在读——显然乌克兰教堂有个习俗，如果有人去世，你要以那人的名义给教堂捐款。所以他真的在列举名字和捐款金额。如果金额多，他会微笑，像“麦斯特·泽斯林斯基，50美元。”他会带着一丝微笑。如果是小数目，他会像（你知道的）“扎格洛斯基一家，五美元。”然后露出失望的表情，就像“哦，不太好，你知道吗？”他一遍遍念着这份名单，人们都在心里合计着钱数。
So then he decides he's going to do a little bit of a eulogy.
然后他决定做一点悼词。
Yeah. He does a eulogy in English, for us, because he knows that we really don't speak Ukrainian. So he comes right in front of us, and he says--
是的。他为我们做了段英语悼词，因为他知道我们真的不懂乌克兰语。他直接来到我们面前，说——
And Andrea's maiden name is Drobish, D R O B  I S H.
安德里亚的娘家姓是德罗比什，D-R-O-B-I-S-H。
And that was my grandmother's name, was Barbara Drobish. So he comes right in front of us, and he says--
那是我的祖母的名字，叫芭芭拉·德罗比什。所以他直接到我们面前说——
He says, "Barbara Drobish was a good lay! Dee!"
他说，“芭芭拉·德罗比什是个好炮友！Dee！”
And that just killed us!
那简直笑死我们了！
"She tried so hard to be a good lay-- dee!" So then Andrea's sister and her, they start to laugh, and they're shaking when they're laughing, and they're trembling. And I think people, especially the people in the Ukrainian church, thought they were literally crying, like, weeping very hard. So the people from the Ukrainian church are now coming and surrounding them, and hugging them.
“她努力想成为一个好炮友——Dee！”于是安德里亚和她妹妹开始笑，她们笑得浑身发抖，战栗不止。我想人们，尤其是乌克兰教堂里的人，以为她们真的在哭，哭得很伤心。所以那些人纷纷围过来安慰她们。
"Oh, the poor grandchildren!" And they're crying, which is making us laugh.
“哦，可怜的孙女们！”他们都在哭，这让我们笑得更厉害。
Everyone is crying except us, who are laughing hysterically, and trying to hide the fact that we're laughing, and trying not to mock the Ukrainian church. So that's our--
除了我们歇斯底里大笑、试图掩盖事实、不想嘲笑乌克兰教堂之外，所有人都哭了。这就是我们的——
And that's the funny story.
这就是那个有趣的故事。
I like it!
我喜欢！
You like it?
你喜欢？
I think it's funny. It reminded me of a Seinfeld .
我觉得挺逗的。让我想起了《宋飞正传》。
So she didn't bust a gut. But maybe for my mom, that only happens at funerals.
所以她没笑得肚子疼。但也许对我妈来说，那只能在葬礼上发生。
Really funny!
真的好笑！
Wait, I don't get the final line.
等等，我没听懂最后一句。
The last line was, she didn't bust a gut, but she only does that at funerals.
最后一句是：她没笑得肚子疼，但她只有在葬礼上才会那样。
But she did bust a gut.
但她明明笑了。
No, she didn't bust a gut. That's the problem.
不，她没笑得肚子疼。问题就在这儿。
She laughed!
她笑了啊！
I feel like you guys are dwelling on the last one. That was amazing.
我觉得你们太纠结最后那句了。那真的很棒。
That was great.
真的不错。
I wasn't dwelling. I just, there was a moment I was confused.
我没有纠结。只是有一刻我困惑了。
I'm nervous.
我好紧张。
Yeah, I know! Beat that.
我知道！打败它。
I know! You reported the crap out of it. That was what made it so amazing.
我知道！你做足了报道。那才是它精彩的原因。
I thought we were supposed to.
我还以为我们应该那样呢。
No. I did some reporting, but I thought that was going to be my strong suit. I was like, well, my story sucks, but I did some reporting. But I didn't do as much reporting as you did.
不。我做了一些报道，但我以为那是我的强项。我当时想，好吧，我的故事烂透了，但我做了点报道。不过我没你做得那么多。
All right. Well, our next story is from Nancy Updike, who recorded this story, but couldn't be here with us.
好吧。下一个故事来自南希·厄普代克，她录制了这个故事，但没能来到现场。
I talked to my dad. He pitched me this idea a year ago, actually. Kind of caught me off-guard with this one. The Erie Canal.
我和我爸谈过。其实他一年前就向我推荐了这个点子。这事儿还真把我问住了。伊利运河。
What about the Erie Canal?
伊利运河怎么了？
Well, you know, it's a famous old waterway, dug with a lot of brutal labor, manual labor, a lot of it, and it was a tremendous feat of engineering, and generated lots of songs, and there was traffic that went along it, and things like that. But it didn't last very long. I mean, the railroads came, and then the trucks came, and water transport went out of fashion. You know. And the question is kind of, what's become of it?
嗯，你知道，这是一条著名的古老水道，用极其残酷的体力劳动挖掘而成，产生了许多歌曲，曾经车水马龙。但它没持续多久。我是说，铁路来了，后来卡车来了，水运就过时了。你知道。问题是，它现在成什么样了？
And before I answer that question, I just want to quickly remind our listeners of everything they, of course, already know about the Canal. Longest canal in the U.S., when it was built. 363 miles. Linking Lake Erie and the rest of the Great Lakes to the Atlantic via the Hudson River, dug by hand, with shovels and pre-industrial tools, before our country was even 50 years old. And it was our first big success in physically uniting the United States by connecting the built-up east coast with the midwest.
在回答这个问题之前，我只想快速提醒我们的听众关于这条运河他们当然都已经知道的事情。它是美国建成时最长的运河。363英里。通过哈德逊河连接伊利湖和其余大湖区到大西洋，用铲子和前工业化工具手工挖掘，那时国家还没成立50年。这是我们通过连接发达的东海岸和中西部，在物质上统一美国的第一个巨大成功。
This is Craig Williams, curator at the New York State Museum.
这是纽约州立博物馆馆长克雷格·威廉姆斯。
It must have been tremendously exciting. They were doing something unprecedented. They were building a canal to the moon. And it must've been tremendously confidence-building for a society that was still an incredibly young republic that they could pull something like this off.
那一定极其令人振奋。他们做了一件前所未有的事。他们是在建造一条通往月球的运河。对于一个还极其年轻的共和国来说，能完成这样的成就，一定极大地增强了信心。
So I did find out what became of the canal, and some things you just cannot express in words alone. The canal is too big, so I wrote a song with my friend, Dave Hill.
所以我查清了运河的现状，有些事情你不能只用语言表达。运河太大了，所以我和我朋友戴夫·希尔写了首歌。
[SINGING] Give it to me, woman.
[唱歌] 给我吧，女士。
Easy, easy!
慢点，慢点！
They were building a canal to the moon. A canal to the moon.
他们在建造一条通往月球的运河。一条通往月球的运河。
[SINGING] What do you do with a canal to the moon, when the railroad gets to there a lot more soon? You'd rather drive your car, anyway. And you don't want to go from Buffalo to Albany. But let's say you're a nuclear power plant, and you need massive concrete containers for your spent fuel rods. You could do a lot worse than shipping via the Erie Canal.
[唱歌] 当铁路很快就能到达那里时，你拿这条通往月球的运河干什么？况且你宁愿开车。而且你也不想从布法罗去奥尔巴尼。但假设你是个核电站，你需要巨大的混凝土容器装乏燃料棒。走伊利运河总比别的方法强。
It's still in use.
它还在使用中。
[SINGING] So you call up Rob Goldman at the New York Sate Marines Transportation Authority, because--
[唱歌] 所以你打电话给纽约州海运管理局的罗布·高德曼，因为——
If you want to go from New York to Montreal, it could save you a thousand miles.
如果你想从纽约去蒙特利尔，它可以为你节省一千英里。
True.
确实。
It could save you a thousand miles.
它可以节省一千英里。
He already said that.
他已经说过了。
[SINGING] But what do you do with a canal to the moon when your town or your city has passed its industrial boom? No more million of tons of cargo floating by. [SPEAKING] More like thousands. Better than nothing, but still. How about this, though?
[唱歌] 但当你的城镇或城市工业繁荣期已过，你拿这条通往月球的运河干什么？没有百万吨货物漂过。[说话] 更多是几千吨。总比没有好，但也差不多。不过这个怎么样？
You could hike, you could bike. The trail is now being completed across the state.
你可以远足，你可以骑行。这条步道现在正在全州范围内完成。
[SINGING] He's talking about a 360 mile trail alongside the canal system that's two-thirds complete. Quite a feat! And don't forget--
[唱歌] 他说的是运河系统旁全长360英里的步道，已经完成了三分之二。相当了不起！而且别忘了——
In many places, the locks are parks, so you could just go and have a cookout. There are tables there. You could read a book, take a nap, go to a restaurant, bring your kids, feed the ducks.
很多地方的船闸就是公园，所以你可以去野餐。有桌子。你可以看书、小睡、去餐馆、带孩子、喂鸭子。
Ducks? Everyone likes ducks.
鸭子？每个人都喜欢鸭子。
I like ducks.
我喜欢鸭子。
It just goes on and on.
它就这么一直延伸。
[SINGING] And on and on and on and on and on and on and on.
[唱歌] 就这样一直、一直、一直……
What do you do with a canal to the moon when some people, maybe you, complain three, four times a year, in op-ed, up in Rochester, saying--
当有些人，比如你，一年投诉三四次，在罗切斯特写专栏说——
Why are we spending all this money for rich people to take their yachts from Florida to Lake Erie?
我们为什么要花这么多钱让富人开着游艇从佛罗里达去伊利湖？
[SINGING] But here's what you do with a canal to the moon. Put a canoe in it, or a tire, or a kayak--
[唱歌] 但这就是你拿这条通往月球的运河做的：放只独木舟，或者轮胎，或者皮划艇——
Or like a floaty lawn chair.
或者像浮动草坪椅。
Go ice fishing. Play hockey. It's water.
去冰钓。玩曲棍球。这是水。
This one guy was telling me the canal was makeout city.
有个家伙告诉我运河是约会胜地。
[SINGING] That's what you do with a canal to the moon.
[唱歌] 这就是你拿这条通往月球的运河做的。
[SPEAKING] It was the eighth wonder of the world when it was built. You're not just going to fill it with concrete.
[说话] 它建成时是世界第八大奇迹。你不能就这样用混凝土填掉它。
We nailed it.
我们成功了。
Well everybody, what do you think? Nancy Updike, with Dave Hill, by the way.
好了大家，你们怎么看？顺便说一下，南希·厄普代克和戴夫·希尔的作品。
Yay!
耶！
Very inventive.
非常有创意。
I think it's great.
我觉得很棒。
I don't know, I mean, I know kind of a little more about the Erie Canal, but I still can't picture the--
不知道，我是说，关于伊利运河我确实多了解了一点，但我还是无法想象——
Yeah, I agree. I feel like I don't really know anything, actually, about the Erie Canal.
是的，我也同意。我觉得其实我还是对伊利运河一无所知。
I think you guys are missing the point of this story. That was kickass! She wrote a song! And performed it!
我觉得你们错过了故事的重点。那太酷了！她写了首歌！还表演了！
All right. Well, our next story is from Alex Blumberg.
好了。下一个故事来自亚历克斯·布隆伯格。
My dad doesn't watch much TV. He hates sports. He's an atheist. His main pastime is reading. Books on Buddhism, philosophy. He loves William Blake and science books and left-leaning blogs. And his story ideas, they're generally big and abstract.
我爸不怎么看电视。他讨厌体育。他是无神论者。他的主要消遣是阅读。佛教和哲学书籍。他喜欢威廉·布莱克、科普书籍和左翼博客。他故事的点子通常很大且抽象。
For example, when I called them for this project the other night, one idea he thought I should do a story about is the idea of coming out of the closet. This idea has been so key, he said, in advancing the cause of gay rights, and he wanted me to do a story about how other groups should adopt the tactics of coming out in order to seek mainstream acceptance. What other groups? Atheists. Also, people who don't like sports.
例如，前几天晚上我为这个项目打电话给他时，他想出的一个点子是“出柜”。他说，这个点子在推进同性恋权益事业中非常关键，他希望我做一个关于其他群体应该如何采纳“出柜”策略来寻求主流认可的故事。哪些其他群体？无神论者。还有，不喜欢体育的人。
His other idea, at least initially, seemed equally as unpromising.
他另一个点子，至少最初，看起来同样没戏。
The fact that law treats corporations as if they were people.
法律对待公司就像对待人一样这一事实。
He'd been thinking about the idea of corporate personhood for years, but it was especially on his mind during the conversation I had with him, which took place just a couple of days after that Supreme Court decision overturning large parts of campaign finance law. That decision, the Citizens United case, basically said there is no distinction between a corporation spending a lot of money on a campaign and a regular person doing it. In the eyes of the law, the corporation can buy as many ads as it wants. To my dad, that seems crazy and dangerous.
他思考“公司人格”这个点子好几年了，但在我们那次谈话时他特别在意这个，因为那是在最高法院推翻竞选财务法部分条款的裁决几天之后发生的。那项裁决，“联合公民案”，基本上说公司花巨资竞选和普通人这样做没有区别。在法律眼中，公司可以买它想要的任何广告。对我爸来说，这看起来疯狂且危险。
We've kind of created these Goliaths, these Godzillas, parading around as if they were people. But in fact, they have a kind of power that no individual person could ever begin to amass.
我们创造了这些巨人，这些哥斯拉，像人一样在大摇大摆。但实际上，他们拥有任何个人永远无法企及的力量。
Right.
对。
So there is this entity called Exxon Corporation, and you read newspaper stories about Exxon says, or Exxon was furious.
所以有家叫埃克森美孚的公司，你读报纸故事时会看到“埃克森美孚说”或者“埃克森美孚很愤怒”。
You've never read a sentence that said "Exxon was furious." Have you?
你从没读过一句说“埃克森美孚很愤怒”的话，是吧？
Well, Exxon was upset.
嗯，埃克森美孚很不高兴。
So who should I talk to, though?
不过，我该找谁谈呢？
Well, I think that's the story idea. Is who do you talk to? Who becomes the voice of Exxon?
嗯，我认为这就是故事的重点。找谁谈？谁变成了埃克森美孚的代言人？
So the idea would be, I would call-- I would try-- it would be in search of Exxon.
所以计划是，我会尝试——这会是一场对埃克森美孚的搜索。
In search of Exxon. Who is this? We treat them as a person. And who do they think they are? Who do you think you are!
寻找埃克森美孚。这是什么东西？我们把他们当作一个人对待。他们以为自己是谁？你以为你是谁！
All right. I will try to do that. I'll try to find out who Exxon thinks they are.
好吧。我会试着做的。我会试着找出埃克森美孚认为他们是谁。
I'm not going to lie. This didn't go well. I called Exxon, spoke to a media relations person there, told her about how my dad and I had this conversation, and I wanted to find out who Exxon thought it was. The lady was very nice, but she said she didn't see any reason Exxon would ever want to talk to me about this. In this way, Exxon is just like a lot of people. If they don't want to talk to the media, you can't really make them.
我不想撒谎。这事儿进展不顺。我给埃克森美孚打了电话，跟公关人员说了我爸和我那次谈话，以及我想找出埃克森美孚认为自己是谁。那位女士人很好，但她说她看不出埃克森美孚为什么要在这方面跟我谈。在这点上，埃克森美孚就像很多人一样。如果他们不想跟媒体谈，你真没辙。
I called around to other multinational corporations. Same answer. Then I tried the U.S. Chamber of Commerce, the trade group for most of American business. The guy there was a little bit more receptive, and he called me back with the name-- Eugene Volokh. He's the guy you should talk to. Although when I reached Eugene Volokh, he couldn't explain why the Chamber of Commerce sent me to him.
我打给其他跨国公司。答案一样。然后我试了美国商会，大多数美国企业的贸易团体。那里的伙计更乐于接受，他回电给了我一个名字——尤金·沃洛赫。这是你应该找的人。虽然当我联系到尤金·沃洛赫时，他解释不了为什么商会要把我推给他。
You know, I am not sure. I think somebody at the Chamber of Commerce reads my blog.
你知道，我不确定。我想商会有人看我的博客。
So Eugene Volokh turns out not to be a spokesman for corporate America in any way. He's a charming libertarian-leaning law professor at UCLA. He runs a popular blog called the Volokh Conspiracy, though he's written a lot about constitutional issues in the Citizens United case.
所以尤金·沃洛赫根本不是美国企业的代言人。他是加州大学洛杉矶分校一位迷人的自由意志主义法学教授。他经营着一个叫“沃洛赫阴谋”的流行博客，虽然他写了很多关于“联合公民案”宪法问题的文章。
And the more we talked, the more I had to let go of my Michael Moore dreams-- asking stunty questions designed to expose the fallacy of corporate personhood, such as, what's Exxon's favorite color? Or what does Exxon want for Christmas? Or who's Exxon's favorite Beatle? That line of questioning, Eugene Volokh told me in so many words, is stupid.
我们聊得越多，我越得放弃我的迈克尔·摩尔式的梦想——那些旨在揭露公司人格谬论的特技提问，比如：埃克森美孚最喜欢的颜色是什么？埃克森美孚圣诞节想要什么？或者埃克森美孚最喜欢的甲壳虫成员是谁？尤金·沃洛赫直言不讳地告诉我，这种提问是愚蠢的。
Corporations are generally seen as having many constitutional rights, but it's not because somehow they're metaphysically persons. It's because restricting corporations in various ways restricts the rights of persons. It restricts the rights of their owners, and it restricts, perhaps, the rights of others.
公司通常被认为拥有许多宪法权利，但这并不是因为它们在形而上学上是人。这是因为以各种方式限制公司会限制个人的权利。它限制了所有者的权利，可能也限制了其他人的权利。
Others being, for example, people who want to hear what the corporation has to say.
其他人是指，例如，想听公司说话的人。
All right. I'm just going to stop here and say, by the time I got to this point in my conversation with Eugene Volokh, I already knew that the story my dad wanted me to do was in trouble. So Dad, if you don't mind, I took up a different question. The question I took up is this. How worried should he be about the Citizens United case?
好吧。我在这儿打住，说一句：当我跟尤金·沃洛赫聊到这里时，我已经知道我爸让我做的故事要完了。所以爸爸，如果你不介意的话，我换了个不同的问题。我研究的问题是：他应该对“联合公民案”有多担心？
OK. A little background on the idea of corporations as people. When it comes to property rights, corporations are basically the same as you and I. The government can't take away their property without due process. That's protected under the fourteenth amendment. But when it comes to something the fifth amendment, which says, you can't be forced to incriminate yourself in a court of law, corporations are not covered. All those TV dramas and congressional hearings where people plead the fifth? Exxon can't do that.
好的。关于公司是人的概念背景：在产权方面，公司基本上和我们一样。政府不能在没有正当程序的情况下剥夺其财产。这受第十四修正案保护。但当涉及第五修正案（即不能强迫在法庭上自证其罪）时，公司是不涵盖在内的。那些电视剧和国会听证会上人们可以“援引第五修正案”的场景？埃克森美孚做不到。
So corporations are legally like people in some respects, and unlike them in others. And it's in this context that the issue of corporate spending on campaigns comes up. The Supreme Court has dealt with this issue a handful of times over the last century--
所以公司在某些方面像人，在某些方面不像。正是在这个背景下，公司竞选支出问题出现了。最高法院在上个世纪处理过几次这个问题——
OK. Stop the tape. Stop the tape. OK. I'm just going to point out what's going on here. Paul, our engineer, with all due respect, briefly fell asleep. Alex, meanwhile, had to leave to go to a meeting for his other-- he works on Planet Money , and they had a big meeting, so he's not even here to defend himself.
好吧。停止录音。停止录音。好吧。我只想指出这里发生了什么。保罗，我们的工程师，恕我直言，睡着了。同时，亚历克斯不得不离开去参加他另一个——他在做《金钱星球》节目，他们有个大会议，所以他甚至不在这里为自己辩护。
I just, I stopped-- yeah. I went somewhere else.
我只是，我停下来——是的。我去别处了。
Well, I know, no. And we did an edit on it the other day and I said, in this section, like, I didn't follow it at all. And then Ira said that that was because--
我知道，不。我们前几天剪辑时我说，这部分，我完全没听懂。然后艾拉说那是为了——
He said it was because we were girls.
他说是因为我们是女孩。
That was a joke!
那是个笑话！
I just want to say that I really did like that he took his dad's idea and said it didn't work, I'm going to redirect, do my own idea. I thought that was a very clever-- I did think he's a good son to take it on.  So.
我只想说，他能采纳他爸的点子，然后说“这行不通”，转而做自己的点子，这我很欣赏。我觉得他是个好儿子，愿意接手。所以。
They should be proud that he just did such a boring--
他们应该为他做了这么无聊的——
All right. So it's looking very, very bad for Alex in our competition. Coming up-- more stories pitched by our parents, who by the way, we all love very, very, very much. That's in a minute from Chicago Public Radio and Public Radio International when our program continues.
好了。所以亚历克斯在我们的竞争中情况看起来非常、非常糟。接下来的节目——更多由父母推荐的故事，顺便说一下，我们大家都非常、非常、非常爱他们。一分钟后，从芝加哥公共广播电台和国际公共电台，我们的节目继续。
It's This American Life from Ira Glass. It is our 400th episode, and if you're just tuning in, we're doing something very different. After all these years of family members pitching us stories for the show, this week we actually go out and make the stories that our family members pitched. The staff of the radio show and I are sitting here in our office meeting room-- hi everybody, again. We're listening to each of the stories, and at the end of the hour, we're going to decide which story was best, which parent pitched the best story. Whoever it is will get a prize. We're also asking you to vote online at thisamericanlife.org. Our next story up is from producer Robyn Semien.
这是艾拉·格拉斯的《美国生活》。这是我们的第400期，如果你刚调到这里，我们正在做非常不同的事。多年来家人们一直向我们推荐故事，这周我们真的出去制作了他们推荐的故事。我和节目的工作人员坐在我们的办公室会议室里——再次向大家问好。我们正在听每个故事，节目结束时，我们要决定哪个故事最好，哪个父母推荐的故事最棒。无论谁获胜都将获得奖项。我们也在邀请你们在线访问thisamericanlife.org投票。下一个故事来自制作人罗宾·塞米恩。
When I asked my dad to think of an idea he'd like to pitch, he took it to mean one thing. A clear opportunity to tell his favorite story.
当我叫我爸想一个他想推荐的点子时，他以为只有一件事。一个讲述他最喜欢的故事的明确机会。
Believe it or not, this is all the way back in 1950. That's right. 1950. So this is before--
信不信由你，这事儿追溯到1950年。没错，1950年。所以这是在——
It's like before the invention of fire, Dad. You're making this sound like--
这就像火的发现之前，爸。你说得好像——
This story usually takes him a little over an hour to tell. it's about how he souped up a car when he was 20. But before he tells you about that car, he always tells you about another car, his starter car, a 1953 Oldsmobile.
这个故事他讲起来通常需要一个多小时。它是关于他20岁时如何改装一辆汽车的。但在讲那辆车之前，他总是先讲另一辆车，他人生第一辆车，一辆1953年的奥兹莫比尔。
When he was growing up in Richmond, California, which is near Oakland, there was a fad among teens to take some chrome off a car and paint primer where the chrome used to be. My dad took the trend a step further. He took the door handles off his car-- that's right, the door handles-- and painted circles of gray primer where the handles used to be.
他在加州里士满长大，靠近奥克兰。当时青少年中间流行一种风尚，把车上的镀铬件拆掉，在原来的地方涂上底漆。我爸把这种潮流更进一步。他把车门把手拆了——没错，是门把手——在把手原来的位置漆上了灰色的圆圈。
That would have been cool. There wasn't a whole lot of people running around that had cars that didn't have door handles on them, and naturally, they'd want to know, how do you open the door?
那一定很酷。当时没几个人开着没门把手的车，自然，他们会想知道：你怎么开门？
You'd open the door, or my dad would open the door, by pressing the button he'd hidden in the chrome trim of the car. It was an electric button that triggered a solenoid which released the door latch. My dad was obsessed with electronics, and wondered what else in the car he could trick out. The radio, the lights.
我会开门，或者我爸会开门，通过按他隐藏在车身镀铬装饰条里的按钮。那是个电子按钮，触发一个电磁铁释放门锁。我爸痴迷于电子产品，想知道车里还有什么能改装。收音机、车灯。
One day, I don't know why. It just came to me-- well, sure would be nice if there was only one switch. If I had one switch to control all of this. And just as fast, it came to me, now, how could you possibly have one switch to do everything? That's impossible. And so just as fast as the idea came up, the idea went way. Because I said, that's impossible. Don't make any sense.
有一天，不知道为什么，那个念头闪过了——嗯，要是只有一个开关该多好。如果我有一个开关能控制这一切。转念一想，怎么可能用一个开关做所有事？这不可能。所以那个点子随着产生很快就消失了。因为我说，这不可能。完全没道理。
After a while, my dad bought about another car-- a used '56 Lincoln Premiere convertible. And the attraction was that everything in the car was electric. Power seats, power windows, the convertible top. It was a perfect laboratory for my dad.
过了一阵子，我爸又买了一辆车——一辆二手56年的林肯Premiere敞篷车。吸引人的是车里一切都是电动的。电动座椅、电动车窗、敞篷顶。这对我是个完美的实验室。
His job at the time was at a place where they were manufacturing parts for CB radios, and these particular CB radios had rotary dials on them, like on a telephone, connected to a switch inside. And it was at work one day, inspecting those rotary dials, when it hit him. He had his Thomas Edison moment.
那时他在一家生产CB电台零件的工厂工作，那种电台上有旋转拨盘，像电话上的那样，连着里面的开关。有一天工作时，检查那些旋转拨盘，他突然灵光一闪。他有了自己的托马斯·爱迪生时刻。
If you dial three to switch it, it moves three times. If you dial six [? digits, ?] it moves six times.
如果你拨三下开关，它就动三次。如果你拨六下，它就动六次。
And I looked at that, and it just came back to me. I said, there's my switch. There is my switch.
我看着那个，念头又回来了。我说，我的开关在这儿。我的开关就在这儿。
For the next eight months, my dad locked himself in his room. His plan was this. He'd attach all of the car's power circuits to a metal box using hundreds of relays, all controlled by a rotary dial from an old Princess phone, the kind which had a little light behind it. This was the star of the show, and needed a prime location-- the center of the steering wheel.
接下来的八个月，我爸把自己锁在房间里。计划是这样的：他会把车里所有的动力电路连到一个金属盒上，用数百个继电器，全部由一个老式公主电话的旋转拨盘控制，那种带点微光的。这是节目的主角，需要一个绝佳的位置——方向盘中心。
So I guess the reward for doing all of that was the day when it was finally finished, and I put it in the car. And I call your grandfather out, and he came out and sat in the car. And so he was sitting over on the passenger side, and he was leaning up, had his arm on the window. And I said, well, this is what I was doing. An he kind of looked at it like, what were you doing?
所以我猜做完这一切的奖励就是终于完成的那天，我把它装进车里。我叫我爷爷出来，他坐进车里。他坐在副驾驶那边，倚着窗。我说，嗯，这就是我做的。他看着它，就像是说：你在做什么？
And my hand reached for the steering wheel, towards the princess dial, and he saw the light turn on as my hand reach for it. It was a cute little trick. I had a switch underneath my brake pedal, on the floor, that put power to the dial. I could not have power to the dial at all times. Anybody could play around with that switch and make all that stuff happen. They may not know what's going on.
我的手伸向方向盘，靠近公主拨盘，他看到我手伸过去时灯亮了。那是个可爱的小花招。我在刹车踏板下的地板上装了个开关，给拨盘供电。我不能一直让拨盘带电。别人可能会玩那个开关，把所有东西都弄出来。他们可能不知道怎么回事。
So when I reached for it, the light turned on, which powered it. And I dial one, I dial twice, I dial three times. And when I dial the fourth time and the  engine started-- and then I saw his eyes kind of-- no, that didn't just happen.
所以当我伸过去时，灯亮了，电源接通。我拨一下，拨两下，拨三下。当我拨第四下时，引擎发动了——然后我看到他的眼睛有点——不，那不可能发生。
But before he had a chance to really recover from that, I dialed three more numbers real quick, and all of a sudden, the windows started coming up, moving his arm off the side of the door. And I dialed three more numbers, and the other window came up, and I dialed three more numbers, and the top started coming up.
但他还没来得及从震惊中恢复，我又飞快地拨了三个数字，窗户突然开始升起，把他靠在车门上的胳膊顶开了。我又拨了三个，另一扇窗升起，我又拨了三个，车顶开始升起。
And so I just kind of flooded. I kept dialing, dial after dial after dial, real fast, to make all these things operate, before he ever had a chance to think about it at all.
所以我简直像疯了。我不停地拨，一个又一个，飞快地拨，让所有这些东西运作，他连思考的机会都没有。
So you did it.
所以你做到了。
I did it. One switch. And my daughters, they never knew about it. I didn't talk too much about it. They were around it all of their life, growing up.
我做到了。一个开关。我女儿们，她们从不知道这事。我不怎么提。她们从小就在它周围长大。
That's my sister Shaun and me laughing in the background. My dad really thinks we don't know that story.
背景里那个笑的是我和我姐姐肖恩。我爸真的以为我们不知道那个故事。
Shaun, how many times do you think you've heard the car story?
肖恩，你觉得你听过这个车的故事多少次了？
Probably a couple of times a year for like, as long as I can remember. So I don't know. 30, 50, something like that.
大概一年几次吧，从我有记忆开始。所以我不知道。30、50次，差不多吧。
I've heard the story at least as many times as my sister. My uncle Rocky, who was 16 when my dad built the Lincoln, probably heard it the most.
我听这个故事的次数至少和我姐姐一样多。我叔叔洛基，我爸做那辆林肯时他才16岁，他可能听得最多。
Oh God! At least a hundred times.
噢，天呐！至少一百次。
My friends Ellen and Anya have both heard it, separately. My boyfriend Damien.
我的朋友艾伦和安雅都听过，分别听的。我男朋友达米安也是。
Yeah, I've heard it. In detail, probably twice. But loosely six or seven times.
是啊，我听过。详细的可能两次。但零散地六七次。
In fact, the night my dad pitched me the car story, my niece Alexis, who is 15, was listening. Alexis also had a story idea, but we never got to it, because when my dad started on the car story, she couldn't outlast him.
事实上，那天晚上我爸向我推荐这个车的故事时，我15岁的侄女亚历克西斯也在听。她本来也有故事点子，但我们没来得及听，因为当我爸讲起车的故事，她没能撑住。
And I got like really tired, and I just knew that it probably was just going to keep going like that. So I decided that I should probably get some sleep.
我真的很累，我知道它很可能会一直讲下去。所以我决定我还是去睡觉吧。
The whole thing that got me was the-- and just as quickly as the idea came, it went away! Because I knew that can't be the end of the story. Obviously there's a whole other section.
整个事情让我入迷的是——那个念头随着产生很快就消失了！因为我知道那不可能是故事的结局。显然还有一大段别的。
Right. You know he's just, like, ramping up.
没错。你知道他只是在起势。
Exactly.
确实。
My nephew Jamison, who's 11, also heard that story that same night. My dad says Jamison's the lucky grandchild who will inherit the box and dial. Jamison's take on the story?
我11岁的侄子杰米森也那天晚上听到了故事。我爸说杰米森是幸运的孙子，会继承那个盒子和拨盘。杰米森对这故事的看法？
Um-- if I were, like, more patient, then it would have sounded like a good story.
嗯——如果我能更有耐心点，那听起来会是个好故事。
When we were young, there was a lesson attached to this story-- that when you put your mind to it, you can accomplish anything. But when I asked my dad today why this is the story he tells over and over, what's the point of the story, he says he's just proud that he had an idea that nobody else did. I point out to my dad that his invention was completely impractical. It's way harder to dial a secret code than to just push the button that opens the window. He says that's not the point. It was cool. It made him stand out. And if anyone wanted the window down, or the radio on, they had to go through him.
我们年轻时，这故事里有个教训——只要你动脑筋，什么都能完成。但今天我问我爸为什么一遍又一遍讲这个故事，这故事的重点是什么时，他说他只是很自豪自己有了别人没有的点子。我指出他的发明完全不实用。拨个秘密代码比按个升窗按钮麻烦多了。他说那不是重点。那很酷。这让他脱颖而出。如果有人想降下窗户或打开收音机，他们都得找他。
Nice.
不错。
That was so nice.
那太好了。
That was amazing.
那太棒了。
I love your dad.
我爱你的父亲。
Well, that worked so well, because it was about him. Like, it wasn't outside of him. But not just that, but you made it not the story, but about the fact of it-- yeah, that was cool.
嗯，那个做得太好了，因为它讲的是他自己。它是关于他内在的。不仅如此，你做的时候不是只讲故事，而是讲关于它本身的事实——是的，那很酷。
OK. So this is a good place to say that two of our producers put together stories that didn't work out so well. Alissa Shipp, one of our producers, called her mom, and got into this pretty heavy conversation. And the most air-able part of it was this one moment that they got talking about this moment with her grandmother in the hospital. And it's 16 seconds long.
好了。这是一个好地方来说，我们的两位制作人做出的故事结果不太好。我们制作人之一阿丽莎·希普给她妈打了个电话，陷入了一场相当沉重的对话。其中最能播出的片段是她们聊到她祖母在医院的那一刻。只有16秒。
Bubbe on her deathbed, actually, last time I visited her, and she was kind of whispering something. And we bent down to listen to her, and she said, I'm bored.
实际上，我最后一次去探望临终的祖母，她正低声说着什么。我们弯下腰去听，她说：我好无聊。
Does anyone else think that's funny?
还有人觉得这很好笑吗？
I think that's funny. I feel like it's like my nightmare. That's exactly how I imagine it being, too.
我觉得好笑。我觉得这就像我的噩梦。我也正是这么想象的。
And then our next story is from Sarah Koenig. Also a shortie.
接下来的故事来自莎拉·凯尼格。也是个短的。
So my mom's story idea wasn't, strictly speaking, a story, or, strictly speaking, an idea. It was about a conversation she's had dozens of times with my daughter Ava, who's six.
我妈的故事点子严格来说不算故事，也不算点子。它是关于她跟我六岁的女儿艾娃谈过几十次的话题。
My granddaughter always me why I celebrate Christmas. Well, why do you do Christmas? You're Jewish. Well, I said, my parents did it, and it's a big tradition in our family, and we liked it, and I wanted to carry on the tradition. And she said, but you're Jewish! Why do you do it? She's never content with my answer.
孙女总是问我为什么要庆祝圣诞节。嗯，你为什么要过圣诞节？你是犹太人。嗯，我说，我父母这样做，这是我们家的一个大传统，我们喜欢，我想把它传下去。她说，但你是犹太人！你为什么要这样做？她从不满足于我的回答。
I figured maybe there was some cognitive reason for Ava's confusion, like that at her age, she simply could not compute the contradiction that somebody Jewish would do something not Jewish.
我想也许艾娃的困惑有什么认知原因，比如在她那个年纪，她简单地无法理解“有人是犹太人却做非犹太人的事”这种矛盾。
So I talked to a couple of child psychologists, and they told me I was right. That this question is taxing Ava's prefrontal cortex. That's the part of the brain where we store information about rule-governed behavior, like how we're supposed to act. And they said it might take a couple of years for Ava's prefrontal cortex to get it.
所以我跟几个儿童心理学家谈过，他们说我是对的。这个问题正在消耗艾娃的前额叶皮层。那是大脑中我们存储关于规则行为信息的部分，比如我们应该如何行事。他们说可能还要几年艾娃的前额叶皮层才能理解。
This is Karen Bierman. She's written books about child development.
这是凯伦·比尔曼。她写过关于儿童发展的书。
Your daughter's right at that cusp. She's got a category, she's got a clear category of what it means to be Jewish, and her grandmother doesn't fit that category in any way that she can see. So that's a more challenging cognition.
你女儿正处于那个临界点。她有一个类别，她对“身为犹太人意味着什么”有一个清晰的分类，而她祖母的任何行为都无法放入那个分类中。所以这是一种更具挑战性的认知。
Anyhow, none of this felt very, um, gripping.
总之，这听起来一点都不引人入胜。
So to sum up, I wrote a little ditty about Ava's situation with her grandmother, who she calls Yaya. The tune is borrowed, by the way.
所以总结一下，我写了个关于艾娃和她祖母（她叫亚亚）情况的小曲子。顺便说一下，曲调是借用的。
[SINGING] When your Yaya gets a tree, and you know that it shouldn't be, look her straight in the eye, ask why.
[唱歌] 当你亚亚买了棵树，你知道那不应该，看着她的眼睛，问为什么。
[SINGING] Ask why--
[唱歌] 问为什么——
Ask why--
问为什么——
Don't you eat that Christmas stew. You're a Jew. You're a Jew--
别吃那圣诞炖菜。你是犹太人。你是犹太人——
You're a Jew--
你是犹太人——
Me too--
我也是——
Me too-- [GIGGLES]
我也是—— [咯咯笑]
That's it.
就这些。
More songs! I like it.
更多歌！我喜欢。
I would have ended the song a little earlier. I had enough of the cuteness. I was ready for it to end, like, 20 seconds earlier.
我会早点结束这首歌。那种可爱劲儿我已经够了。我准备好让它早个20秒结束了。
But the giggle? Give me a break.
但那个咯咯笑声？算了吧。
The giggle's pretty good. You just hate children and Jews.
笑声挺好的。你只是讨厌小孩和犹太人。
It's true. We never have any kids. We never have any Jews.
真的。我们从没小孩。我们也从没犹太人。
All right. Well, our last story today comes from Jane Feltes.
好了。今天最后一个故事来自简·费尔特斯。
I called my dad, and obviously he was super stoked to help me with this project.
我给我爸打了电话，显然他非常乐于在这个项目上帮我。
Here's the thing. It's pretty boring these days, and especially here in sunny Michigan. But if you want ideas, here's some stuff.
是这样的。现在很无聊，尤其是在阳光明媚的密歇根。但如果你想要点子，这里有一些东西。
That was my dad's attempt at modesty. Turns out he's kind of a pitching machine. The stuff I could do stories about range from, Can you believe GM is bringing 800 jobs to Michigan, rather than moving them out? Or, why you guys follow up on that story you did a few years ago about some vigilante border patrol guys down on the Mexican border?
那是我爸试图谦虚一下。结果他简直是个点子机器。我可以做故事的东西包括：你能相信通用汽车正在把800个工作岗位带回密歇根，而不是迁走吗？或者，为什么你们不跟进几年前做的关于墨西哥边境那些自卫队边境巡逻人员的故事？
I want to know if they're still there, and if they finally got guns.
我想知道他们还在那里吗，以及他们最后有没有拿到枪。
Then somehow we got on the topic of how to make solar energy efficient, which led to the wave particle duality of photons, and not led to--
然后不知怎么我们就聊到了如何让太阳能高效，引出了光子的波粒二象性，没引出——
So does the particle aspect come in regular intervals, brrrr, like a machine gun? Or if they go pop, like popcorn?
所以粒子方面是按固定间隔来的吗，像机枪一样？还是像砰砰砰爆米花那样弹跳？
Right. And then naturally--
对。然后自然——
You know, like how big does a planet have to be to have a molten core?
你知道，行星要多大才会有熔岩核心？
And then finally--
然后最后——
I think Harry Brakeman is fascinating.
我觉得哈里·布雷克曼很迷人。
What?
什么？
You know Harry Brakeman?
你知道哈里·布雷克曼吗？
At first I was like, who? But then I remembered that Harry Brakeman was the pastor at my Grandma Ruth's Methodist church a while back. Now he's retired, and he and his wife live in eastern Michigan, out in the country.
起初我在想是谁？但我记得哈里·布雷克曼是祖母露丝的卫理公会教堂以前的牧师。现在他退休了，他和妻子住在密歇根东部，乡下。
They live in this little tiny house over in Port Huron, like Ruth and Bill's house, like, you know, 1,200 square feet. They started this school down in Haiti, which is an American thing to do. We like to do that. Go out in the world and start schools to make people like us. And it turned into a university.
他们住在一个休伦港的小房子里，像露丝和比尔的房子那样，你知道，1200平方英尺。他们在海地办了一所学校，这是件很美国人的事。我们喜欢那样。走向世界，办学校让人们喜欢我们。结果它变成了一所大学。
What?
什么？
Yeah. Brakeman University. Medical school, I think they're trying to put together. They've got a four year college with, I think they have some grad programs. Brakeman University, is what it's called. Methodist church--
是的。布雷克曼大学。医学院，我想他们正在筹建。他们有四年制学院，我想有研究生课程。布雷克曼大学，就是它的名字。卫理公会教堂——
I kind of doubted this story from the jump. Like, maybe he had a church there, and it's possible that they taught a Sunday School, but then someone was talking to somebody, and it turned into a game of telephone, and in the end, everyone in Michigan thinks Harry Brakeman's like running the Harvard of the Caribbean.
我一开始就怀疑这个故事。比如，也许他在那里有个教堂，教会有人主日学是可能的，但有人传话给某人，这就变成了一个传话游戏，最后，密歇根每个人都觉得哈里·布雷克曼在加勒比海办了哈佛大学。
Their story fascinates me. And it was Harry's deal from the beginning to the end.
他们的故事让我着迷。从头到尾都是哈里的交易。
OK. So that phone call, that was a week before the earthquake in Haiti. So when the earthquake happened, then I found myself worried about this school that I didn't even know if it existed.
好吧。那个电话是在海地地震前一周打的。所以当地震发生时，我就发现自己担心起这个我甚至不知道是否存在学校了。
I was born right here, almost where I'm sitting right now.
我就出生在这里，几乎就在我现在坐的地方。
Ladies and gentlemen, Harry Brakeman, 87 years old, in his home in Clyde, Michigan. And Harry says it's true. There is a school.
女士们先生们，哈里·布雷克曼，87岁，在他密歇根州克莱德的家中。哈里说是真的。有那么一所学校。
Back in the '70s, a missionary visits Harry's church, and he's talking about some work he's doing in Haiti, and would Harry want to join and help. So in 1976, the Brakemans fly into Port-au-Prince for the first time.
70年代，一位传教士访问哈里的教堂，讲他在海地做的工作，问哈里愿不愿意加入帮忙。于是1976年，布雷克曼夫妇第一次飞往太子港。
We got a truck to pick us up and took us to a church. [UNINTELLIGIBLE] says you're preaching here today. I was like, I'm what? He said, you're preaching! So [? Bells Head Farm ?] was the largest Protestant church in Port-au-Prince, and I never had such a experience in my life. But I was scared. My knees were almost shaking, knocking. And I said, Lord, you've got me in a mess, and you've got to get me out of here. But he didn't.
我们找了辆卡车接我们去教堂。[听不清] 说你今天在这讲道。我说，我什么？他说，你要讲道！所以[农场钟声]是太子港最大的新教教堂，我一生中从未有过那种经历。但我害怕。我的膝盖简直在发抖，磕磕碰碰。我说，主啊，你让我陷入了麻烦，你得让我脱身。但他没让我脱身。
And I'm not an evangelist. I've never done that kind of work. I was just always a pastor. But when I got done with preaching, the people just flooded to the altar. In fact, the team called me another Billy Graham.
我不是个传教士。我从没做过那种工作。我一直只是个牧师。但讲道结束后，人们涌向圣坛。事实上，团队称我是另一个比利·格雷厄姆。
Now, I've heard Harry's sermons, and to tell you the truth, they sound pretty much like this conversation. He's not all filled with the spirit or anything. So you can see how special this was. He toured around the island and saw how people live.
现在，我听过哈里的布道，说实话，它们听起来就像这段对话。他不是充满圣灵什么的。所以你可以看出这有多特别。他巡游岛屿，看到人们生活状况。
And that opened my eyes up a lot. I've never seen people so poor in my life. My heart was broken. My pocketbook was broken, too.
这极大地开了我的眼。我一生从未见过如此贫穷的人。我的心碎了。我的钱包也碎了。
His missionary work took him to a small town called Petit Goave, or Ti Goave, about 40 miles west of Port-au-Prince on a two lane highway. It's a fishing town on the coast. Kind of a commercial center for all the tiny villages in the mountains that surround it. They were building churches, and Harry had the idea to build a school.
他的传教工作带他去了小镇佩蒂特戈夫，或蒂戈夫，太子港以西约40英里的双车道高速公路上。那是个沿海的渔镇。是环绕周围山区所有小村庄的商业中心。他们在那儿盖教堂，哈里有了办学校的点子。
The work was hard, hauling construction supplies from Port-au-Prince and working crazy hours to avoid the midday sun.
工作很辛苦，从太子港运建筑材料，为了躲避中午的阳光而疯狂工作。
What wasn't as difficult was finding volunteers. When Michigan construction jobs dried up every winter, Harry said they found plenty of people happy to spend a few months warming up in Haiti.
找志愿者就不那么难了。每到冬天密歇根建筑工作停滞时，哈里说他们发现很多人很高兴去海地暖和几个月。
We'd gone back, and then we started back in those villages. They'd have rice mats in their houses, and they'd let us sleep [? on those. ?] And we would sleep and work, work and sleep. I remember, I started singing a song-- Learn to lean, learn to lean, learn to lean on Jesus, finding more strength than I've ever dreamed, I've learned to lean on him. We would often start singing that when things got kind of rough, at first.
我们回去，然后在那里的村庄重新开始。他们房子里有稻席，让我们睡在上面。我们睡觉工作，工作睡觉。我记得，我开始唱一首歌——学会依靠，学会依靠，学会依靠耶稣，找到比我梦中更多的力量，我学会了依靠他。事情变得艰难时，我们通常会开始唱这首歌。
As the students grew, the classes grew, and so on and so forth, until they had 650 students and 42 teachers, all of them Haitian. They taught preschool through junior college, and then two years ago added university level courses. They were affiliated with a medical campus in Port-au-Prince. At least, that was the case up until a month ago.
随着学生人数增加，班级也增加了，一直到有650名学生和42名老师，全都是海地人。他们教授从学前班到大学预科，两年前又增加了大学课程。他们与太子港的医学院分校建立了联系。至少，一个月前还是这样。
So tell me about what's going on in Petit Goave now.
所以告诉我佩蒂特戈夫现在怎么样了。
As far as we know, the only damage to our school-- last year, they put a room on top of the auditorium to house computers in. We understand that's fallen down. But the rest of the school is still usable.
据我们所知，我们学校唯一的损坏——去年，他们在礼堂上方建了个房间存放电脑。我们得知那塌了。但学校其余部分还能用。
Three weeks after the earthquake, I asked a newspaper reporter from New Jersey, Meredith Mandell, who was traveling to Haiti to do her own story, if she would go, or at least try to go, to Petit Goave, and find the school, and if she found it, was it standing?
地震三周后，我问一位新泽西的报纸记者梅瑞狄斯·曼德尔，她正要去海地做故事，是否能去，或者至少尝试去一趟佩蒂特戈夫，找到那所学校，如果她找到了，它还在吗？
Meredith said that these helicopters were flying really low overhead the whole time she was there. Eventually, she found the school.
梅瑞狄斯说，她在那里时，直升机一直在头顶低飞。最终，她找到了学校。
Wow.
哇。
Now you see this room fell down here, where we had, I thought, this is the college area Brakeman. The best school in Petit Goave. And everybody knows about that.
现在你看到这间屋子倒在这儿，我以为这是布雷克曼大学区。佩蒂特戈夫最好的学校。每个人都知道它。
But as you see, for example, on the left side of the school, that all the walls fell down. That one you see here, we had  the computers room that fell down here.
但如你所见，例如在学校左侧，墙都倒了。那个，你在这儿看到的，我们存放电脑的房间就在这塌了。
The guy she's talking to is Luc Lespenasse whom Harry put me in touch with. Luc's known the Brakemans for years. He met them when he was a teen, back when they first visited Petit Goave. In the '80s, he came to live with them in Michigan for a few years, and they put him through college. They call them their Haitian son.
她说话的人是卢克·莱斯佩纳斯，哈里帮我联系上的。卢克认识布雷克曼一家很多年了。他十几岁时认识他们，那是他们第一次访问佩蒂特戈夫时。80年代，他搬到密歇根跟他们住几年，他们供他读大学。他们管他叫“海地儿子”。
The original classrooms were solidly constructed with rebar support, and all finished nicely. Kind of looks like it could be a high school in southern California And those buildings, they're still standing, though they do have that empty, frozen in time feeling. Like the date of the quake, January 12, is still written on one of the chalkboards in teacher's handwriting.
最初的教室结构坚固，有钢筋支撑，装修得也很好。看起来像南加州的高中。那些建筑还在站着，不过它们确实有一种空洞的、时间静止的感觉。地震日期——1月12日，还写在其中一块黑板上，是老师的字迹。
But a few recent additions to the school were thrown up with cinderblocks, and they've come down. The new computer lab is just piles of rubble. But overall, the school fared pretty well compared to the rest of Petit Goave, which was essentially leveled. Not only was it hit in the first quake, but that 5.9 magnitude aftershock that happened a week later? The epicenter was right beneath Petit Goave. So the school is kind of the last thing on anyone's mind.
但学校最近加盖的一些建筑是用煤渣块搭的，它们倒了。新的计算机实验室只剩瓦砾。但总的来说，学校比起佩蒂特戈夫其他地方表现好多了，那里基本被夷为平地。不仅在第一次地震中受损，而且一周后那场5.9级余震，震中就在佩蒂特戈夫正下方。所以学校现在是没人想的事儿。
I had a long talk with Luc on the phone, but without thinking, I made the mistake of starting with the standard non-emergency disasters on small talk.
我和卢克在电话里谈了很久，但没多想，我犯了个错误，用了那种灾后非紧急谈话的闲聊方式开头。
Luc?
卢克？
Yes?
在？
Hi! This is Jane.
嗨！我是简。
Oh, yes. How have you been?
哦，在。你最近好吗？
I've been OK. How about you?
我挺好的。你呢？
Oh, just so-so. In a few words, I would say things are really bad. But where I am at in Petit Goave, there are so many houses that have been destroyed, also with a lot of people inside.
哦，一般般。简而言之，我说情况非常糟糕。但在佩蒂特戈夫我这儿，有很多房子被摧毁了，还有很多人在里面。
With people inside?
有人在里面？
Yes, yes.
是的，是的。
For years, Luc's run an ad hoc orphanage out of his house, which is now uninhabitable. Altogether, since he started, he's taken in 172 kids. Right now he has 15 boys, seven of them he's legally adopted.
多年来，卢克在自己家里经营一家临时孤儿院，现在那里已经没法住人了。总共，自他开始以来，收留了172个孩子。现在他有15个男孩，其中七个是他法律上收养的。
So what are you doing during the day, you know, most days?
那么这几天你在做什么？
You mean right now, or in the past?
你是说现在，还是过去？
Right now, like this week. How are you spending your days?
现在，就这周。你是怎么过日子的？
Oh, dear. Right now, I can say, if I ask you if it is right now or in the past, that's because right now, we have a new Haiti. This is-- I can say we are in another world. I'ts not the same in the past.
哦，天哪。现在，我可以说，如果我问你是指现在还是过去，那是因为现在我们有一个新海地。这是——我可以说我们处在另一个世界。跟过去不一样。
He said his boys were keeping themselves busy, playing dominoes, basketball. Help has been slow to arrive to Petit Goave. Medical teams didn't get here until a week after the quake. Stores are down, and even if they weren't, Luc can't access his money because the banks were destroyed. More kids show up every day asking for help. He says everyone is just waiting, but they're not even sure what they're waiting for.
他说他的孩子们让自己忙着，打牌、打篮球。对佩蒂特戈夫的援助到达很慢。医疗队在地震一周后才到。商店倒闭了，即使没倒，卢克也取不到钱，因为银行被毁了。每天有更多孩子出现寻求帮助。他说每个人都在等，但他们甚至不确定自己在等什么。
Right. I feel embarrassed doing a story about trying to figure out what's happened to Harry's school when there are obviously so many other questions that are more important, you know?
对。做关于试图查明哈里学校发生了什么的故事时，我很尴尬，因为显然有很多更重要的问题，你知道？
Yeah. I know what you mean. But anyway, you know that Harry-- many Haitian people consider Harry Brakeman as a Haitian or so.
对。我知道你的意思。但总之，你知道哈里——很多海地人把哈里·布雷克曼当成海地人，真的。
Many people there count Harry as a Haitian, Luc says.
卢克说，那里很多人认为哈里是海地人。
A lot of things he's been doing for us. A lot of schools and a lot of church. His heart is really with us. So one of the reasons that we are glad to name the school after him, College Harry Brakeman.
他为我们做了很多事。很多学校和教堂。他的心真的和我们在一起。所以我们很高兴以他的名字命名学校，哈里·布雷克曼大学。
I spoke to him the other day, and he seemed to think that school could continue, you know, somehow. But I don't think he understands how bad it is.
我前几天和他谈过，他似乎认为学校可以继续，你知道，以某种方式。但我认为他不明白情况有多糟。
No, I don't think so, I don't think so. Me, I talked to his wife on the phone. You know, for some reason, I did not tell them all I've been telling you. Because they so care for the people here. I felt it will embarrass just to tell them exactly what happened. For example, I can say in Petit Goave only, we have more than 1,000 people die.
不，我不认为他明白。我跟他的妻子通过话。因为某种原因，我没把告诉你的实情全部告诉他们。因为他们太关心这里的人了。我觉得告诉他们到底发生了什么太让他们尴尬了。例如，我可以说仅在佩蒂特戈夫，我们就有超过一千人死亡。
Luc said it's a thousand. The official count, according to the mayor, is more like 1,100 so far. And that's in a town of roughly 12,000 people.
卢克说是上千人。根据市长说法，目前官方统计是1100左右。那是在大约一万二千人的小镇。
And by the way, I would like to ask you also to help us in your prayers.
另外，我也想请求你在祷告中帮助我们。
In our prayers?
在我们的祷告中？
Yes, yes. So we hope that you won't forget us in your prayers.
是的，是的。所以我们希望你不要在祷告中忘了我们。
I like a lot about this story. I mean, I think you were so hampered by crummy-- two sets of crummy tape-- like most of your subjects are really hard to understand. You know what I mean? Like you really had a lot of work to do in this story as a narrator. And I think you did it. I mean, I think you take us through.
这个故事我很喜欢。我是说，我觉得你被两组烂磁带限制得很厉害——我是说你大部分采访对象都很难听懂。你懂吗？你作为讲述者在故事里真的做了很多工作。我觉得你做到了。我是说，我觉得你带我们过了一遍。
I liked the moment of where you said that your dad had pitched this to you before the earthquake, and then the earthquake hit, and all of a sudden you found yourself wondering about this university that you weren't even sure actually really existed. And I thought that was my favorite part, was to come at the end, and like, now we care about a university in a town I've never heard of. I really liked that.
我喜欢你提到你父亲在地震前就推荐了这个点子，然后地震来了，突然你发现自己开始关心这个你甚至不确定是否真实存在的大学。我觉得这是我最喜欢的部分，最后我们真的开始关心一个我闻所未闻的城镇里的一所大学。我真的很喜欢。
I feel like I'm on American Idol.
我觉得自己像在《美国偶像》节目上。
OK. So it's time to vote. We've heard all the stories. Just to review on what those stories were one more time. It was my dad's story the suit on the train, Lisa's story about the funny funeral, Nancy's story about the Erie Canal, Alex's story about corporations as people, Robyn's story about her dad's rotary phone-controlled car, Alissa's story about her bubbe's deathbed boredom, Sarah's story about Christmas and her daughter and her mom, and Jane's story about the college in Haiti.
好了。现在是投票时间。我们听完了所有故事。再复习一下。那是我爸在火车上的西装故事，莉莎关于有趣葬礼的故事，南希关于伊利运河的故事，亚历克斯关于公司人格的故事，罗宾关于她爸的拨盘控制汽车的故事，阿丽莎关于她祖母临终无聊的故事，莎拉关于圣诞节、她女儿和她妈妈的故事，还有简关于海地大学的故事。
Are there criteria for voting?
投票有什么标准吗？
Yeah, there's indefinitely criteria. And I think you should consider all of the criteria when, I think, thinking about-- well, there's just the, expertise, there's entertainment, level of difficulty--
有，肯定有标准。我觉得你应该考虑所有的标准——专家程度、娱乐性、难度等级——
Yeah. How hard was the pitch from the parent?
对。父母推荐的难度有多大？
Yeah. If you had to listen to one again, what would you listen to?
对。如果你必须再听一遍，你会选哪一个？
That's a good way to think about it.
这是个好想法。
Yeah, I know. And for me, that would narrow it down for me to Lisa and Robyn.
对。对我来说，那会把范围缩小到莉莎和罗宾。
That would narrow it down, to me, to Lisa and Nancy.
对我来说，会缩小到莉莎和南希。
Yeah. Lisa's story about the funny funeral, Nancy's story about the Erie Canal, for me it would be Lisa's story about the funny funerals and Robyn's story about the car.
对。莉莎关于有趣葬礼的故事，南希关于伊利运河的故事。对我来说，莉莎的有趣葬礼故事和罗宾的汽车故事。
Yeah. I'm going with Lisa.
对。我投莉莎。
I'm going with Lisa, too.
我也投莉莎。
I was going to say Robyn.
我本来想说罗宾的。
I'm torn between Robyn and Jane.
我在罗宾和简之间纠结。
Robyn's story about the dad's car and Jane's story about Haiti, why? Why those two?
罗宾关于她爸汽车的故事，简关于海地的故事，为什么？为什么是这两个？
Well, going into it, I was like, oh, it's Robyn. Because it just felt like such a solid story. It just, well--
嗯，开始的时候，我觉得是罗宾。因为它感觉就像一个非常扎实的故事。它……嗯——
Not like that usual crap we put out here.
不像我们平时放的那种垃圾。
Yeah. It was like, I mean, I'm not a fan of This American Life, so I don't, like, seek it out, but if I have to listen, like, that would have been pretty good, you know?
对。就是，我是说，我不是《美国生活》的粉丝，所以我不会去找来看，但如果我非听不可，那是相当不错的，你知道吗？
But then with Jane's, it's like, that is such a-- it goes in such an unexpected place, and it was hard.
但简的那个故事，它去了一个意想不到的地方，而且它很难。
I'm going to make a little push for Nancy here as well. Just because Erie Canal. That is hard. That is really hard. And I feel like, contrary to some here, I feel like I did learn quite a lot about the Erie Canal.
我要为南希拉拉票。就因为伊利运河。那很难。那真的很难。而且我觉得，跟有些人相反，我觉得我真的从伊利运河那里了解到了很多。
I did too.
我也了解到了。
And totally entertaining. So I feel like she really hit the three criteria.
而且非常有趣。所以我感觉她真的打中了三个标准。
Yeah, but you remember the first like minute and a half of Nancy's piece, which is just like these incredibly boring pieces of factual information?
是啊，但你还记得南希作品开头那一分半钟吗，全是极其无聊的琐碎事实？
I think it's all a red herring so the song hits you-- it's still in the service of the song. I appreciated the stagecraft of that.
我觉得那都是烟雾弹，为了让那首歌出来时更有冲击力——它还在服务于歌曲。我很欣赏那种舞台设计。
OK. So I'm just going to take a little score here. So I'm voting Lisa. Julie?
好了。我来统计一下分数。我投莉莎。朱莉？
In an all-around, package, kind of best-in-show kind of way, I enjoyed Lisa's the most.
以整体包和全场最佳的角度，我最享受莉莎的。
OK. Lisa?
好了。莉莎？
I'm going to go for Robyn.
我投罗宾。
Alissa?
阿丽莎？
Robyn.
罗宾。
Sarah?
莎拉？
After pushing Nancy, really-- I'm really torn between Lisa and Nancy. Nancy.
在为南希拉票后，说真的——我在莉莎和南希之间非常纠结。南希。
OK. Seth?
好了。塞斯？
Jane.
简。
Jane?
简？
Lisa.
莉莎。
OK. Robyn?
好了。罗宾？
Lisa.
莉莎。
OK. The final tally. Lisa, you have four votes. Nancy has one, Robin has two, and Jane, you have one.
好了。最终统计。莉莎，你有四票。南希一票，罗宾两票，简，你有一票。
Congratulations, Lisa.
恭喜你，莉莎。
Congratulations, Lisa!
恭喜你，莉莎！
Thank you. Thanks.
谢谢。谢谢。
Have fun with your parents.
和你父母玩得开心。
Yeah!
耶！
By the way, they have to say with you.
顺便说一句，他们必须和你住在一起。
Our program was produced today by Sarah Koenig and myself with the greatest documentary production staff in radio-- Alex Blumberg, Jane Feltes, Lisa Pollak, Robyn Semian, Alissa Shipp, and Nancy Updike. Our senior producer is Julie Snyder Our intern, who is already making our stories better, is Brian Reed. Seth Lind is our production manager. Emily Condon is our office manager. Music consultant, Jessica Hopper. Audio engineering for today's shows by Paul Ruest.
我们的节目今天由莎拉·凯尼格和我本人制作，拥有广播界最伟大的纪录片制作团队——亚历克斯·布隆伯格、简·费尔特斯、莉莎·波拉克、罗宾·塞米恩、阿丽莎·希普和南希·厄普代克。我们的资深制作人是朱莉·斯奈德。我们的实习生，已经在让我们故事变得更好的布莱恩·里德。塞斯·林德是我们的制作经理。艾米丽·康登是我们的办公室经理。音乐顾问，杰西卡·霍珀。今天的音频工程由保罗·鲁斯特负责。
[ACKNOWLEDGEMENTS]
[鸣谢]
Special thanks today to our parents, especially the ones who we interviewed who didn't make it into the show. Don't forget to go to our website and vote. We really are curious what the audience favorite is for today's show. We went your vote. The web address is www.thisamericanlife.org.
今天特别感谢我们的父母，尤其是那些接受了我们采访但没能上节目的。别忘了去我们网站投票。我们真的很好奇今天节目观众的最爱是谁。我们需要你的投票。网址是www.thisamericanlife.org。
At our website, you can also listen to Alex Blumberg's complete story, the one that we cut off in the middle.
在我们的网站，你还可以听到亚历克斯·布隆伯格完整的故事，那个我们讲了一半切掉的。
If you happen to be an iPhone user, there's also a link at that site to a new iPhone app that gives you all 400 of our episodes at your fingertips which is three bucks. The app also has amazing extras, like David Sedaris's first few radio stories, or I also interview Terry Gross and she interviews me, and there's a free behind-the-scenes video of our show, there's an amazing cartoon slide story done by Chris Ware.
如果你恰好是iPhone用户，该网站上还有个链接到新的iPhone应用程序，触手可及我们的全部400期节目，只要三块钱。该应用还有惊人的额外内容，比如大卫·塞达瑞斯最初的几篇广播故事，或者我采访特里·格罗斯，她采访我，还有我们节目的幕后免费视频，有克里斯·威尔做的精美卡通幻灯片故事。
This American Life is distributed by Public Radio International. WBEZ management oversight for our 400 episodes by our partner in all this, Mr. Torey Malatia, who does not understand why Lisa Pollak's funny funeral stories should win number one.
《美国生活》由国际公共电台发行。WBEZ对我们400期节目的管理监督，由这一切的合作伙伴，托里·马拉蒂亚先生负责，他不明白为什么莉莎·波拉克有趣的葬礼故事应该获得第一名。
What was so funny? What was so funny, Mitch?
什么那么好笑？米奇，什么那么好笑？
I'm Ira Glass. Back next week with more stories of This American Life.
我是艾拉·格拉斯。下周带更多《美国生活》的故事回来。
Barbara Drobish was a good lay-- dee.
芭芭拉·德罗比什是个好炮友——Dee。